so you guys have a lot of experience it
looks like that's good uhhuh yep
excellent yeah what do we do with this
level 38 yeah 38 I'm the low level in my
group of how Jesus Christ how much do
you stream man this is one game like
three or four days a week how let me see
how many hours I've got in this game uh
32.9 hours okay that's not as bad as I
thought but yeah damn it's like a level
an hour I'm the Newbie typically so it's
going to be weird for me guiding you
guys what do you mean You' got 38 hours
how can you not know what's going on
32.8 I can feel your fear as you found a
note like this inside your house what is
this note I don't know if it applies
because I've already done it so that
might be something you guys don't want
to spoil you know once you put 30 hours
in the game then you'll unlock it uh-huh
yeah it's from someone signed Das s you
don't
think a
baby oh who's ass I don't know all right
fine I'm hold on this music is driving
me nuts both of you are default bald guy
the same how can I change that yeah yeah
over here on the far right one if you at
the top arrows go over to customize
character then the bottom right click
customize character and then you can um
go to appearance and you can change your
appearance okay IA don't have any
wardrobe options right now what no um
got
why is underwear matter are we ever
going to be
underwear you can choose to be only an
underwear wait this guy who doesn't know
about
underwear hey wait how do I look God
damn
it how do I it's it has a touch icon but
I'm it's not allowing me to touch I want
to touch it's purin you probably look
see
okay hey Mark
[Laughter]
how has this happen hey Wade hey Wade
how you
doing you're not saying anything I'm
just so disappointed in what do you
mean what do you went
wrong Mark and I clearly are on the same
page I you had a lightning bolt on your
neck I I just clicked it but a light
behind you did you notice whenever you
turn the light off his hair turns brown
with the light on it's purple sounds
like you need to get better graphics
cards purple all the way through for
me oh I see what you mean
thanks thanks Mr double 490 you need a
5090 oh I see I see what you mean I see
oh yeah you're you're right
anyway uh welcome to demonologist you
guys get to vote on our map since I've
unlocked all the ones that are out so
far Mark do you see my teeth I see your
teeth I was uh looking yeah I see your
teeth oh I see a lot of teeth yeah
rotate your mouse around you can really
get the full oh yeah glad they put a
tongue in there neat yeah that's nice my
cat is still oh
he's he's eating a lot is he getting
fatter oh yes oh wow he's actually just
getting fatter yes that is a
feature wow that's that's great so
what's the point of this
game uh well I'm glad you asked think
we
monitors this is my safe house this is
the penthouse safe house it's it's nice
so we have a list of tools I have what I
think we
need again I'm not an expert and I'm
kind of
broke a good
kitty a good KY I feel like my guidance
is being abused right I'm listening keep
going who's a good kitty who's a good
kitty so if you guys want to vote on a
map
uhhuh oh that's cute that's cute kitty
that's cute kitty I'll
just but you guys do have to ready up
don't worry we're taking care of the cat
I'm ready uh press space bar I click
that ready button oh okay space bar good
good boy okay you did too many times bad
bad boy okay well we're loading all
right man I hope I was ready when it
loaded yeah I don't really care at this
point you're here so Cyclone
Street whoa yes welcome whoa all right
how much of this stuff can I squander
and how quickly can I do it so you're
going to want a flashlight the
flashlights of the things look like
pipes they they're great ah I know what
flashlights look like the thing you know
flat wait where is it I don't see it aha
yeah got it all right two other tools
like the EMF is the thing with the
Cockroach on it one of you is going to
want the Cockroach whoa what is this
thing that's the ESG you put it on the
ground and occasionally the ghost will
appear above it if that's one of the
clues it's like fasma we we have to get
we to figure out what the GH is why does
the EMF have a cockroach on it uh feel
like that's how they work I feel like
that's different than how I thought they
worked
smile ah I'm sure there's not a limited
number of those is there a limited
number of these I don't know man my 32
hours has honestly not taught me
everything I need to know about this
game those are good
pictures nice why why does that camera
have like a like a Bellows and looks
like it's an old camera but then also it
sounds like a digital D like a DSLR it
does have like a Blackmagic design like
5 in display on the back so this is
definitely got it our objectives are in
here you're I've got an as huh yes whoa
an artist far right screen is our sanity
middle screen different cameras if we
put cameras in there we can wait why is
his Ys dropping so much uh you know
being around y all probably feel like
mine is the lowest somehow I weade was
low for a bit there but not my mistake
uh so we have to do this in order we
have to do the top portion detect the
type of ghost use your tools to detect
the type of ghost once you guess you
lock it in and you cannot change your
Ghost type and if you don't put a guess
in before you die you don't get to guess
oh snap how do you guess J for Guess uh
J and then go to evidence and you want
to put your evidence in then you would
select The Ghost and confirm but you do
not want to do that right now there's a
face in my J oh yeah yeah that's Lilith
they're big Diablo 4 fans okay neat I
made that let's go detect the kind of
ghost it is I'm on it all
right welcome to cyclone Street uh-huh
it's probably one of my favorite Maps is
is the is the eel to get ectoplasm
stains is that what the ghost will
literally like paint you a picture hell
there is a little glass in there that
actually can show you the jiz stains uh
cool I don't know if I want that you do
dude this is kind of creepy what this
hallway this kind of like caved in part
of the hallway bones hanging off cuz the
door rotted otherwise it would be normal
the bones
interesting good picture good picture
some people like bones wow some uh
Egyptian
plunder that's good the whole like Vibe
changed too how do I set down my
isil G I think G or F neat that didn't
work it totally did work oh there it is
okay I mean it did work obviously yeah
you have to do it twice I think you can
rotate it with your mouse too the Maria
room oh yeah so there's when this game
came out there was all kinds of like
speculation this was supposed to be a
big Easter egg was to solve how to get
into this room uhhuh and then apparently
it came out that the uh devs hadn't
actually put a real way to get into it
so people put hundreds of hours into
trying to figure out this riddle to get
in there and apparently it didn't exist
that was mean why would they waste
everyone's time like that I don't know
maybe they'll one day I not be like
turning lights on does that scare ghosts
away or something you can I I think
Spirit Box doesn't work with the lights
are on in the room that the ghost's in
but like otherwise it's fine oh this
looks bad oh go Zu
limo oh um hi huh am I okay yeah you're
fine I don't know why wouldn't you be I
don't know I just had the little screamy
internal bad thing happened what did you
what did you do what did you do I touch
touch the limbo book or something the
limo I standing I was standing right
here do you see this book that says
limbo
who oh
oh is that good or is it there's a lot
of crosses in this hallway oh there's
something the end you opened up the
hallway we will come for you well that's
nice we'll come for you oh
I'll painting that you wait a minute oh
yeah that'll work that writing doesn't
show up on the pictures should I put
down this thing well this isn't
necessarily where the ghost is this is
just like a little Easter egg that
people thought was related to the Maria
room but why did that why that going
backwards ah I can rotate it oh oh oh
hey um oh it's not funny lady it's not
good she definitely liked to
giggle okay I'm also going to tell you
unlike fasmo there are hauntings that
are unrelated to the ghost being near
you so that kind of stuff happening
still doesn't necessarily mean we're in
the right spot oh good but uh we'll get
to screwed with anywhere in this
place okay I don't remember there being
sheets on the wall were there always
sheets on the
wall yes are we sure there's not a way
in here maybe everyone else was just
stupid I mean we can pretend that we can
get in and you can as as you want oh the
drugs are hitting oh you got that see I
got that oh
I thought that was just me are you guys
okay yeah no yeah yeah no hey guys I
think I found the exorcism bedroom okay
it's
okay what else am I supposed to say if
if we if we need that later I think
that's where the exorcism bedroom is all
right I'm on is the all the
cross
yes is that Maria's room no her room is
literally labeled Maria's room you it's
right by the staircase I found the
exorcism office need
milk well I'm back in the normal house
now apparently wait you weren already
emf2 me me me emf2 in the kitchen boys
okay okay I'll be right there did you
check the closets up in the stairs oh
Bloody Mary Bloody Mary Bloody
Mary
it's bloody but what happened it's
bloody I I feel like you shouldn't have
done what you just did I guess well well
I don't know what to tell you I just did
it Mark Mark where are you I'm upstairs
in the Bloody Mary
bathroom which bathroom I keep saying it
that's a good idea Bloody Mary which one
the Bloody Mary bathroom don't make
spooky stuff happen by Me Make It Happen
by you what you talking about uhoh hey
the light exploded or
something oh I don't like that crawling
noise is happening behind me in the
headphones not a fan of that I need oh
who who W EMF 5 EMF 5 EMF 5 Mark em5
where cabinets are opening bad shit's
happening what do you mean right here
EMF 5 what happening all right I think
this is helping yeah take take more
pictures oh wait you know what we need
Mark what art oh wait I left the easel
oh no I left my thing oh you guys better
go get him oh wait no here's the easel
hey Mark you know what we need what
art beautiful yeah just watch it just
watch it all right all of the cabinets
were opening in the kitchen I don't know
if it's up where you are or down here in
the kitchen I was getting an EMF of two
in the oh freezing temps by the way
freezing temps should we be writing this
down yes um we need kitchen art Mark
kitchen art I'll go get my thing my
light just turned off this is a good
plan J in evidence you need to Mark EMF
5 and freezing temps okay EMF
5 freezing temperatures I'm going to go
get my thing okay it also it cannot be
ectoplasm stains it's it's Spirit Box
ESG can it's an
Abad is it is that like an aladdin
except said wrong you're talking about
abidon the
despoiler no I'm talking about aaden
okay
honestly man I don't like being down all
the way in the back alone we will come
for you you good because the ghost is up
front be beep boopy beity
boopity oh it's rumbly is that good
where are you hi what do you want I'm on
the way
back I don't believe in
ghosts don't worry guys I'm not turning
around what do you never turn around
Spirit ghost where are
you uh you got em5 upstairs I'm going to
check upstairs real quick oh
oh sorry I'm very heavy EMF in the
kitchen three what do you want
three take picture four put down this
how old are you
ghost uh I'm hearing a lot of K clunies
but I'm not seeing any of the krunkies
what is the whirly gig supposed to do B
wait said that it might appear above
that yeah it like the ghost will appear
above it if it's ESG you'll we should
stand real close these are very
dangerous and will get us killed if we
play with them but you want to at least
get a photo of those cards I just
dropped oh really can I play with them
if you want to risk death do it I'll
take a picture I mean only if you want
live Mark document this okay you got it
you ready yeah wait uh flame of
fate
oh oh look out behind you
um I think it's okay I think it's okay
who what's that what's going on on the
wall oh neat Mark are you getting
pictures yeah wa oh okay uh see Wade
you're such a worry wart should I pull
another one Mark uh yeah if you want
okay make sure you get it on camera bro
all right you got it Boop
drawing the devil waa
I I
um good oh the devil is opening the
cabinets
oh ghost ghost ghost ghost ghost I saw
it I got a picture of it Mar get the
pictures Mark the pictures the pictures
marked I got it um it's right there it's
above oh hey it did the thing I was in
the I didn't mean did it appear above it
yeah it did it's okay you got a cool
selfie with it so that should be ESG
then ESG yeah it's Ain it's Ain I'm
going to go inside the house now
confirmed I to go outside the house now
what's happening sorry I was writing in
my journal what happened I'm going to
write outside in my journal outside the
house I'm going outside all
right the y y bro that was
not I got a picture of it Mark the balls
the boun balls
whoa is that is that good or so our next
objective is use the ectoplasm glass to
find the time of the ghost's death it
will be written on a wall but you can
only see it through the ectoplasm glass
can we just guess what we need to upload
computer data and then we need to
collect those ghost orbs how how do you
capture a ghost orb also everyone might
want to take some sanity pills cuz we
are [__] oh all right hey my sanity
went from two to 28 all right I'm
feeling good
guys um where's the glass things that we
need uh I I took it in the house so it's
in the kitchen I believe oh oh okay Mark
you might want to take the other one too
cuz you're standing I think still the
lowest no I do I'm fine sure okay so who
wants to go around look for the
time uh I'll do that what is that okay
so literally like it'll be written on a
wall somewhere so right here Bob okay is
the ectoplasm glass so you have to like
right click I think or left click and
it'll like hold it up to you left click
oh dear oh goodness me oh the door
closed is that bad I who it took my
crucifix that's well I say us but uh
whoa okay I got that on camera do you
think these things are leading us
somewhere I they seem to just kind of be
going everywhere I don't know we're to I
found a name oh no it just says smile oh
okay
whatever I don't want to I don't want to
no thank
you is that from um probably
award-winning podcast
distractable oh I think probably
award-winning uh podcast distractable
probably had something as hilarious hit
e on the orbs to collect them oh okay
upload computer data uh
BLK
computer I think I'm doing that come get
a picture of
Blinky all right where's that up here in
the you were just here in the bathroom
over here uhhuh can you tell what that
says oh yeah Bloody Mary blood Bloody
Mary Bloody Mary oh I get it no that
Bloody doing that before I hope someone
is watching this video on a toilet in a
dark bathroom and you just keep saying
that and they're just sitting there
like stop are you holding that up to
your eye when you're looking at the
walls uh and not constantly but I'm
inspecting all the rooms is it going to
be like on the ceiling or the floor or
something think it's usually the walls
okay yeah I've been mostly observing the
walls but I would kind of look all over
the place probably got to go to the back
basement oh computer I shouldn't Touch
This should I well I don't
know oh what happened I've not played
since they added that as a thing to do
so that's kind of an
who oh I caught it I got it who multing
the couch get a picture okay I did good
good dude I'm getting so much good stuff
I don't I don't feel good about this can
I be honest I feel great honestly all we
have to do is find the time now and
we're done with the second set of
objectives wait you got it name was that
a thing what thought you said something
about look for its name on the walls
wasn't that what we were doing look for
the number on the wall the time number
on the walls look for the time on the
walls it's like written you have to use
the ectoplasm glass I didn't realize you
guys abandoned me where are you oh oh oh
oh oh picture oh I'm done I'm done oh no
oh
no hey Mark you all
right uh is it good one all
across
H I walked up Bob he's dead I walked up
here just in time to watch his body fall
from the stairs oh yeah we got to find
that time pretty quick I'm trying
man oh that doesn't sound very good for
me the computer's almost done oh it is
done okay that should mean that this is
hopefully the last objective we I didn't
see any more orbs downstairs did you oh
found it oh
0045 oh sick I'm just going to go
outside for a minute
what's up Mark corpse hey what's up wait
so what are we trying to do though do we
take notes or I think we need to go see
what the objective is it's probably if
it's the same as it used to be set the
time of the ghost's death on the hanging
clocks so we need
0045 so so midnight 12:45 yeah so can I
get a res no honestly there's a chance
you could I think oo is it in the deck
of cards do I need to draw more cards in
the deck of card worry I've got you I
think we can also instantly die from
that but you could bring it back don't
worry I'm going to I'm going to save you
with the deard mark are you ready thank
you yes I drew a card called
slave perfect that doesn't locks the
ghost to its room temporarily Perfect
all right I'm going to draw another one
and this one will save you mark yes I'm
ready I'm by my body ready to
incorporate I'm going to draw another
card real quick because I think I'm
about to die I Dr void Mark that it ate
my last crucifix oh okay all right void
that sounds good void is cool I hear
some thumping going on and I just saw W
go outside well it's just hunted you're
probably okay I'm going to draw another
card Mark I'm going to save you okay
cool the card is slave nice I'm going
draw another card Mark and this one will
save you
yep flame of Fate yes uh he's still dead
which one saves him WID I don't remember
cuz can I just like shuffle through and
pick the one that saves him out of the
deck or no cuz it's random if it's even
in the deck okay I'm drawing another one
Mark I do one called aggressive I'm
going to go stand outside for a minute I
don't know I don't know what aggressive
means but I have an you can't draw them
outside I don't believe wait I know I'm
just going to draw them quickly inside
the door and then just take a oh hey
it's in the kitchen is it hunting huh I
just saw it in oh it was over the thing
over the what youall it ah cuz it's if
it's B if you did the slave be bound to
the kitchen I think the kitchen where it
likes to be all right well then I'm
going to draw another card Mark and this
one will save you I drew a card called
aggressive that doesn't seem good no
it's fine I'm going to uh I'm going to
draw another card Mark okay and this one
will save you okay is it hunting flame
of Fate all right no the front door's
open so oh wait I have bad news about
the front door being open
oh um hey it's coming up the stairs wa
oh it's up the stairs it's up the stairs
oh yeah it's going I think right to
where you are potentially
Wade no he's
fine sounds F it's downstairs it's back
downstairs unless there's more than one
yeah it's yeah it's fine the uh door
won't open oh it's coming back upstairs
Wayne wait it's coming back upstairs
it's up there right now yeah it's up
there look out careful I'm going to try
and draw another
card hey the door the door is open I'm
drawing a card Wade this will help all
right this will help flame of Fate uh-oh
oh my money did all the cards that one
didn't burn in my hand I like I got like
scared and I lowered my hand huh wait
I'm out of cards there's no more cards
ah God dang it all right feel very alive
I'll carry on your legacy thanks grab my
camera there's some cool photos no yeah
I'm going to I'm going to all you need
to do is find the other clocks I got the
one upstairs I'll help wait Bob you stay
outside I'll tell you right where it is
and then you done for it yep Lead Me
Guide Me Daddy all right so I I don't I
think Wade got the only one in the house
so it's got okay so downstairs near the
Maria room Bob you need to go down to
the back all right pretend I said that
oh thanks Mark thank you you're welcome
you both suck yeah it's right by the
Maria room remember 12:4 five good tip
good tip Mark all right I'm looking for
another I think you use key you hit e on
it and then I think you use the arrow
keys to change the time there is another
clock in the other area back here but it
seems to be the only one remember where
you put the easel but it's right at the
entrance of that one oh that's scary
sounds go all the way go all the way
back to where the the limbo thing opened
up all the way to the back there right
there this one Bob you passed it oh yeah
know I see I see I got you thanks thanks
bro
12:45 oh get out of
here get out of here okay I'm I'm Full
Speed Ahead
baby I'm going to I'm going to use the
camera to block yep that's how it work
think that's I think you banished it
ghosts don't like their picture being
taken yep there there's no ghost anymore
you got rid of it run I defeated the
ghost oh this is as fast as I can go
apparently what do I do it only cost two
of us our lives but we did hey I did it
hey you did it I knew I could do it how
do I how do I get out of here
uh go to the car outside and I think you
the door oh classic okay oh you mean to
tell me we fit that tent in all the
equipment in the trunk of this car hey
it's a big this is like an old what is
this an old caddy this is a big TR how
big this trunk is there's still stuff in
damn it's a big trunk okay all right uh
back to the safe house with my success
in hand damn where do I look at the
pictures uh where's the pictures